-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian.
His comedy special
"Slow & Steady"
is streaming now on YouTube.
Let's take a look.
-Was a difficult few months
after the Dahmer show
came out on Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
I was getting texts and e-mails
from people I haven't heard from
in over a decade saying that,
"The guy on Dahmer's show
looks and sounds like you."
[ Laughter ]
Couple kids on the street
even said,
"Hey, Dahmer."
[ Laughter ]
I'll be honest,
if I did even half of the stuff
that Jeffrey Dahmer did,
my dad would be so pissed off.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
the one, the only Joe Pera.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Joe.
-Thank you very much.
Hey, Fred, can I come
to your Thousands hair salon?
-Yes.
-'Cause I could use
about a thousand more hairs.
[ Laughter ]
They combed it over real good
backstage, but, yeah.
-So, Joe, it's so great --
Again, your ability to do,
you know, banter.
[ Laughter ]
You're back in New York City.
You've been on tour
for over a year.
How is it to be back
in New York?
-It's really nice
to be back in New York,
spend some quality time
with my side pieces.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's been tough.
I've been mailing them
$20 Best Buy gift cards
from the road.
But that can only last
for so long.
I don't want to brag,
but I've been buying printer ink
and Nintendo Switch games for
women in three different states.
-Wow.
-Just -- Just -- Just a joke.
-Oh, that's just a joke.
[ Laughter ]
Did you learn things about the
world while you were touring?
I mean, you went
so many interesting places.
-Yeah, it was
really enlightening.
I mean, did you know
that in Ireland,
they don't have
Bluetooth technology?
That's true, and in Australia,
did you know that
when a baby is born,
they give him little kick
in the head?
[ Laughter ]
That's why they're like that.
-I know when you're
out on the road,
you do a lot of crowd work.
Do you find out stuff
about people
from interacting with audiences?
-Yeah, it's probably
my favorite part,
to do research and then --
yeah, and then find out more
by talking with the people
in the crowd.
Yeah, sometimes it's good.
In Grand Rapids, probably
the drunkest city on tour.
They were -- Some woman
was yelling at me
to check out
a Frank Lloyd Wright house
over and over again
and wouldn't stop.
So I was yelling back.
I was saying, "You guys
used to make furniture.
Now you make craft beer
as your big product.
What happened?
What happened to you guys?"
-So you were ready with that
'cause you'd done
research about --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, they used to
make more furniture
than almost any other place in
the country at a certain time.
-Yeah.
I don't want to make them
feel bad or anything,
but she wouldn't stop yelling
about the Frank Lloyd Wright
house.
-Yeah, so at some point,
you got to give him
the hard truths
about the falloff
in their furniture production.
-I think we need
great furniture like this stuff.
-Oh.
You're so -- so sweet.
You -- Is it true that you
actually did crowd work
with someone who had --
who had passed out?
-Yeah, that happened in Aurora.
I do some sleep material,
so it wasn't like a --
It's not out of the ordinary
for them to fall asleep
for periods of time.
But the guy was asleep
the entire show.
-What do you think happens
when you go to a comedy show
and fall asleep
right from the beginning?
-I guess --
I mean, his case, he was...
just drunk and didn't think
about the altitude in Colorado.
I did -- I personally --
I fell asleep at
Conner O'Malley's show one time
'cause I had just moved
that day,
but I wanted to go out
and support my friend.
-Yeah.
-He actually --
He broke character to say like,
"Hey, man, you can go home
if you want to."
-Your special is on YouTube,
which is really exciting
'cause anyone can see it.
But also, YouTube
obviously provides people
a chance to leave comments.
Are you the kind of person who
would read the comment section?
-It gets a little hairy,
and I try not to.
-Yeah.
-There was one comment
I did look at in Instagram.
I put up the Dahmer joke
that you showed,
and somebody said, "Thank you,
sir, for not doing murder."
[ Laughter ]
You know, ha-ha-ha-ha.
But then a person
underneath said,
"The dad in the joke is actually
upset because he's gay."
And it's like, I didn't think --
You know, I don't like
explaining jokes.
That's not fun, and also,
you think that there's, like,
a bottom level of intelligence
on the Internet,
and, you know, and, yeah.
So I just -- Yeah, it sucks
that you have to explain
that that joke is about --
-I mean, I'd love to give --
Yeah, it's about the murder.
And just 'cause you're here,
where do you stand on murder?
Just to clear it up, right.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not okay.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
A lot of times people
can get a little mealymouthed.
It's nice that you came out
and just said it.
-Thank you, yeah, and, no,
being gay is good, great even.
So, yeah, the joke is about
murdering and eating people.
-Yeah, well, I think we can all
laugh at it a little bit more
now that we know that.
-I hope so.
I just --
It never occurred to me
that it could be taken that way.
-Yeah.
Well, now we've cleared it up.
And it's a wonderful special.
And it's always so great
to have you back here.
You guys, that's Joe Pera.
"Slow & Steady"
streaming on YouTube.
We'll be right back
with Chef Ayesha Nurdjaja.